You bring to bear on the world
and a priori perceptual structure,
and that's really an embodied structure
and it's a consequence of the three and
a half billion years that you've
spent putting your body together,
which is a tremendous amount of time
and not only your body but your mind of
course,
because your mind is part of your
body and very much embedded within it.
You know you,
you tend to think that you have your
brain in your head and it's sort of
floating separate from
the rest of your body,
but it's not really true.
Your tremendous massive system of
neurons running through your entire body,
autonomic neurons in the
autonomic nervous system.
Then there on the central nervous system.
So that's a lot of neurons.
And then your central nervous system of
course enables you to exercise voluntary
control over your musculature and
also to receive information from it.
Your brain is really
distributed through your body.
One of the things you may not know is
that people who are paraplegic can walk.
If you,
if you suspend them above a treadmill,
their legs will walk by themselves
with no voluntary control.
So your spine is capable
of quite complex activity.
In fact,
when you walk,
mostly it's a controlled fall and
mostly your spine is doing it and so,
so anyways,
the point of all that is that you don't
have a blank slate consciousness that's
interpreting a world that manifests
itself as segregated objects in some
straight forward.
Since you have a built in interpretive
system that's extraordinarily deeply
embedded and invisible because you
might think about it as the implicit
structure of your unconscious.
It's what it's what gives rise to your
conscious experience and and it presents
you with the world.
That's one way of thinking about it and
it's a good way of thinking about it.
It's the psychoanalytic way of thinking
about it as well as the neuroscientific
way of thinking about it because one
of the things that's pretty interesting
about modern neuroscientist,
especially at the top rate ones,
and those are usually the ones that are
working on emotions as far as I've been
able to tell are are often quite
enamored of the psychoanalysts.
Jaak Panksepp was a good example of that
because they came to understand that
the psychoanalysts insistence
on underlying unconscious
personified motivations
was actually an accurate
reflection of how the brain worked.
And sort of think of yourself as a
loose collection of autonomous spirits.
It's governed by some
overarching identity is,
is,
is a reasonable way of thinking about it.